[ __ ] all that [ __ ] i'm not i'm getting
away from you feel me or if we got an
issue i'm finna get cracking on you it
ain't ain't nothing personal bro you
just a [ __ ] raggedy ass
evil ass [ __ ] shane ass [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] use a [ __ ] listen i don't
disagree with you on on on the kids
character i do think that what he kind
of did was
expose a lot of hip hop to be
exactly that entertainment and i'm not
talking about with the whack thing i
mean just in general like when he got
out of jail and he i mean he seems to be
moving around rather nicely with no not
i mean i i i know like like they
overselling it no no i know um so like
he'd be with a lot of youtubers i've
heard i've heard what you're talking
about i've heard that right but he's a
really
sinister kid
he's a and he's not a kid he's a really
sinister grown-ass man evil ass man
you know he's a really sinister evil ass
man he's really sinister he's really
evil nothing about him is cool nothing
about him is good him dying would be the
best thing to happen to his daughter
like that's how [ __ ] up of a
[ __ ] is he's a horrible human
being that's great his family would be
better off without him he's that
horrible
like you don't meet y'all don't see it
it's hidden behind all the [ __ ] and
this rap [ __ ] or you know he's exposed
he's not
he's evil like he's a different level of
sinister and he's a coward and he's not
willing to be held accountable he's
doing [ __ ] where he know people can't
get to him he goes places in the middle
of times when he know people that he's
not walking up on people and if he's
walking up on him now it's because he
has the support of the federal bureau of
investigation